Google Cloud updates security Command
Center premium pricing for project level
activation is now 25 lower for customers
who use security Command Center to
secure compute engine gke autopilot and
Cloud SQL we've also expanded the number
of finding types available for project
level premium activations to help make
your environment more secure you can now
easily customize the date and time range
of your queries in the log analytics
Page by using the same date and time
range selector used logs Explorer
metrics Explorer and other Cloud Ops
products there are even time range
options such as preset times custom
start and end times and relative time
ranges check out the links below for
everything that we've covered on this
week's